we're talking about how the coronavirus
has dramatically affected college
admissions hundreds of schools including
harvard and yale
will not require s-a-t or a-c-t scores
this year and many families wonder if
that will lead to a permanent change
well the journalist jeff selingo got a
rare inside look
at the application review process he
embedded
in the admissions offices of emory
university
davidson college and the university of
washington this is a very rare thing
this is unbelievable access and his new
book is called
who gets in and why a year inside
college admissions
it's published by scribner an imprint of
simon schuster which is part of vicom
cbs
and jeff selingo joins us now first on
cbs this morning
jeff thank you for being here the first
thing i want to dispel for people out
there is the idea that applying to
college is some sort of meritocracy your
book makes clear it is not
no it was never fair and it never will
be fair we
teenagers seem to think that a rejection
from their dream college is an
indictment on their life
but really what it really is about is
all the
agendas that colleges have all their
priorities that they have
that come through in admissions so they
may want more full pace students
more students from the dakotas so they
have all these priorities that come
through in admissions
so just because a college has a 25
acceptance rate
doesn't mean you have a one in four
chance of getting in yeah i love the
detail
that the typical admissions officer
looks at an application for just about
seven minutes think of the hours and the
agony that go into the application and
then a seven minute review
um but how has the the process changed
from the time when parents might have
been applying to school to now their
kids applying to school
well their kids now are applying to so
many more schools than parents did
eight or ten and so what's now happening
is that the smartest kids from
buffalo and from washington and from
seattle are applying
to the same set of schools all across
the country and now you throw in kids
around the globe applying to those same
schools so a school like emory
university which is one of the schools
that i embedded myself in
just four years ago they had 20 000
applications the year i was there
last year 30 000 applications so a rise
of 10
000 applications just in four years wow
i know a lot of parents and a lot of
kids right now are worried about how the
pandemic will impact their application
they're not part of clubs they could
have been part of they're not
volunteering where they might have
volunteered
how will the pandemic affect the
application process
well the biggest thing i think is the
sat and the act so tomorrow
the sats was supposed to be given to 300
000
teenagers and half of them have already
been cancelled
so what we're seeing as you mentioned in
the introduction we have 400 plus
colleges
that have gone test optional this year
which means they're not using test
scores you don't have to submit them
but yet we still see students out there
seniors trying to get a test score
because in the ambiguity of admissions
we think that number
really matters and what i found in the
year i was embedded in these three
admissions offices is that high school
grades and high school courses matter a
lot more than that test score
yeah and and the grades matter
throughout the senior year so even if
you're in you've got to continue to do
well
because or even if you're you're on the
bubble you've got to continue to do well
because the schools
are still checking believe it or not uh
jeff
you know with this inside look into the
process i'm curious what would you
change how can these schools do a better
job
well one of the things i think they
should stop doing is trying to recruit
all these students who don't have a
chance
in the book i talk all about the direct
marketing and if you have a
teenager who's been going to college
they probably get overwhelmed with
mail on their mailbox and email and
those are from schools that are just
trying to increase
their application numbers they have no
desire in some cases to actually meet
you
so one of the things i would change is
to try to slow down on that and cut back
on that direct marketing because you're
you're increasing students anxiety and
you're encouraging them to apply when
they have no chance
boy jeff i wish your book would have
been around when i was applying because
you can just beat yourself up when you
don't get into the school that you want
so when you say embedded what exactly
were you doing were you watching all the
admissions officers
look at applications so you could see
their thought process i'm fascinated by
what you did
yeah it was totally open process i was
allowed to be there whenever i wanted to
be i could look at any application and i
was reading applications
with them the only thing i couldn't do
is identify them by name but i could
identify
all the other details which i have in
the book and so i would sit there and i
would read and listen to the
conversations they were having about
individual students i was there during
what they call committee
where they meet around a big table and
they're voting up or down
in just the couple of minutes it's
amazing whether to accept somebody or to
reject somebody
you've got to hope that they're in a
good mood that their tummies are full
and they've had a good night's sleep so
if we want to get into college what's
the best thing we need to do
what you can control and so focus on
your high school courses you're going to
take
and the grades don't worry about what
happens in that admissions office
because so much of that is out of your
control
do the best you can do participate in
activities and then let the chips fall
where they may
and and read this new book by jeff
solingo because honestly
the scenes in the book are amazing you
actually see admissions officers moving
kids from
admit to not admit and then back and
you're like oh my god oh man
it's amazing jeff congratulations and
thank you for joining us
and the book again is uh who gets in and
why it is on sale now you'll want to
pick it up